(upbeat music)
(sirens sounding)
♪ All y'all rappers out there ♪
♪ Think y'all hard ♪
♪ Cause what y'all been through ♪
♪ Check it out ♪
♪ It was Friday night chilling ♪
♪ On my front lawn ♪
♪ Me and my crew ♪
♪ I had my bath robe on ♪
♪ Everybody high ♪
♪ Just watched X-Men ♪
♪ Got plenty chicken
heads ready for sex, man ♪
♪ Busters roll up ♪
♪ They trying to talk smack ♪
♪ Don't these (beep) know ♪
♪ They (beeping) with a madman ♪
♪ Dude pull his nine ♪
♪ I knew homie seen us ♪
♪ He pulled two shots ♪
♪ Somehow my penis got between us ♪
♪ I got shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ Shot, shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ But his (beep)'s stills standin' ♪
♪ Shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ Shot, shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ I got shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ But his (beep)'s still standin' ♪
(gunshot firing)
♪ Went back to my palace fast ♪
♪ Now I'm the dude walkin' round ♪
♪ With a phallus cast ♪
♪ Like Wolverine, I'm tryna be a loner ♪
♪ But they think a (beep) ♪
♪ Got an Adam Antium boner ♪
♪ What can I say? ♪
♪ They still up on my totem pole ♪
♪ Bitch, get your tongue ring ♪
♪ Away from the scrotum hole. ♪
♪ Don't know why they love it ♪
♪ but it keeps the ladies moistening ♪
♪ Gave half the honeys in
the hood lead poisoning ♪
♪ Shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ Shot, shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ I got shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ But his (beep)'s still standin' ♪
♪ Shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ Shot, shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ I got shot in the (beep) ♪
♪ But his (beep)'s still standin' ♪
(ethereal background vocalizations)
- Yo, they shot that fool in the (beep).
- God, see (beep) man.
Damn, that hurts.
Damn nah, video over man.
Video's over.
- Ow.
- I'm serious man.
Damn.
♪ Baby baby ♪
♪ It looks like we're back together ♪
♪ And it's like nothing had ever ♪
♪ Torn us apart ♪
♪ Honey, honey ♪
♪ We'll let bygones be bygones ♪
♪ Gonna get our second try on ♪
♪ Gonna have a fresh start ♪
♪ So tonight I'm gonna hit that ♪
♪ Tonight I'm gonna hit that, hit that ♪
♪ Tonight I'm gonna hit that, hit that, ♪
♪ Hit that, and don't try to fight back ♪
♪ The feelings ♪
♪ Sugar, sugar ♪
♪ Just get into my car ♪
♪ And I'll take you so far ♪
♪ From where anyone can see ♪
♪ Lover, lover ♪
♪ Let's just walk and take it slow ♪
♪ In crowded places so they'll know ♪
♪ That you're back with me ♪
♪ So tonight I'm gonna hit that ♪
♪ Tonight I'm gonna hit that, hit that ♪
♪ Tonight I'm gonna hit that ♪
(taser buzzing)
(man screaming)
- I'm sorry, that was
an involuntary reaction.
(taser buzzing)
(car door opening)
(car door closing)
♪ Da struggle in the house ♪
♪ Using words and rhymes
to get through hard times ♪
♪ Yeah, come on ♪
♪ I came from the streets ♪
♪ With nothin' in my pockets ♪
♪ No food, no books,
no power, no sockets ♪
♪ Each model I fight ♪
♪ A role model and a teacher ♪
♪ Hip hop my church ♪
♪ Every rapper a preacher ♪
♪ I preach from my ass ♪
♪ My verse is my sermons ♪
♪ The church is your mouth ♪
♪ Where I shoot my holy sperm in ♪
♪ You could take your role models ♪
♪ Roll 'em on my meat ♪
♪ Bitch is always on the menu ♪
♪ When I go out to eat ♪
(slow serious music)
♪ But everywhere we go ♪
♪ Black women, two jobs ♪
♪ Two kids, too tired to juggle 'em ♪
♪ Juggle 'em, juggle 'em ♪
♪ Jiggity jiggity juggle them ♪
♪ Yum, yum, yummy titty ♪
♪ Titties in my tummy yum ♪
♪ Titties in my mouth ♪
♪ I got titties in my mouth ♪
♪ I got tig old bitties ♪
♪ From a bunch of different cities ♪
♪ I got ♪
♪ There's a light ♪
♪ And it shines within the darkness ♪
♪ Of the sands of time ♪
- The sands of time.
♪ There's a fight ♪
♪ But the battle to be won ♪
♪ Is with the man inside ♪
- The man inside.
♪ No valley or ocean ♪
♪ Can stop my devotion ♪
(horse neighing)
♪ Nothing will keep me
from getting to you ♪
♪ Flying high ♪
♪ To live another morn ♪
♪ Just how I touch the sky ♪
♪ Like a dream ♪
♪ You can never tell a lie ♪
♪ For what's exactly as it seems ♪
♪ In the rhythm I believe ♪
♪ It's the power of wings ♪
♪ There's a fire ♪
♪ And it burns the deepest battles ♪
♪ Of the seven seas ♪
- The seven seas.
♪ True desire ♪
♪ Let the music in your heart ♪
♪ Give way to the things
that you believe ♪
- Anything you can receive.
♪ Flying high ♪
♪ To live another moment ♪
♪ And how I kiss the bride ♪
♪ Ride your dream ♪
♪ You can never tell the lies ♪
♪ From what's exactly as it seems ♪
♪ In the rhythm of the leaves ♪
♪ It's the power of wings ♪
♪ Everything is achievable ♪
♪ Don't let nobody tear you down ♪
- Sexually.
♪ Just take flight ♪
♪ It's believable ♪
♪ If you must, learn
to stand your ground ♪
♪ Flying high ♪
♪ To the moon ♪
♪ How I touch the sky ♪
♪ Like a dream ♪
♪ You can never tell the lies ♪
♪ From what's exactly as it seems ♪
♪ With the rhythms I believe ♪
♪ It's the power of wings ♪
(gentle instrumental music)
♪ Would you look at the time? ♪
♪ You should just stay here tonight ♪
♪ I've had too much wine ♪
♪ You can leave at first light ♪
♪ It isn't that far ♪
♪ Baby just stay where you are ♪
♪ Back to my place ♪
♪ You can't escape from my embrace ♪
♪ I really had a very nice time ♪
♪ Let me just refill that wine ♪
♪ But I really need to just say goodbye ♪
♪ I would like to see you try ♪
♪ Please unlock this door ♪
♪ It's locked from the outside ♪
♪ Babe, you're mine tonight ♪
♪ I cannot stay tonight ♪
♪ Look I really have to go ♪
♪ No you really have to stay ♪
♪ Hey, no means no ♪
♪ That is what they all say ♪
♪ You're hurting my arm ♪
♪ I won't cause you any harm ♪
♪ Let go of me ♪
♪ We can make this hard or just easy ♪
♪ A woman always comes prepared ♪
♪ Oh I'm really scared ♪
♪ I said this is not what I want ♪
♪ Why you have to be such a - ♪
♪ I know self defense ♪
♪ I dare you to try it ♪
♪ I don't wanna fight ♪
♪ Bitch you are mine tonight ♪
(punch landing)
(punches landing)
(slow jazzy music)
- Please just please go away.
♪ I thought you wanted me to say ♪
- Well I just changed my mind.
♪ I think I'll just stay and unwind ♪
- How did this all switch?
♪ Now you are my bitch ♪
- Please just be kind tonight.
♪ Now you're mine tonight ♪
(man gasping)
(audience applauding)
(bright rock music)
♪ Got a pocket full of funky ♪
♪ With a peppermint twist ♪
♪ She's a cold, shifty mama ♪
♪ Blasting off on the flip ♪
♪ Iridescent pork belly ♪
♪ Gallactic supertrain ♪
♪ Mama, sister, playground ♪
♪ With a strong daddy kane ♪
♪ Gotta get it on ♪
♪ Gotta get it down ♪
♪ Gotta make it strong ♪
♪ Got that quick dip cray on her way ♪
♪ Jet pack on a bus ♪
♪ Locomotive supernova ♪
♪ Spanish Harlem son ♪
♪ Slip, drop, and solar blast ♪
♪ With a phosphorescent brain ♪
♪ Who's that mama squat town ♪
♪ Deep fried Detroit soda train ♪
♪ Gotta shake it up ♪
♪ Gotta move it in ♪
♪ Gotta put it down ♪
♪ Gotta make it swim ♪
♪ Man you light a comet
sanitation disease ♪
♪ Tornado, reap and tickle, we sneeze ♪
♪ Since playing is just as can ♪
♪ It's cables and trees ♪
♪ Got to stop this penguin ♪
♪ 'Till these railroads appease ♪
♪ I said remember don't ya? ♪
♪ Mel Brooks, book train ♪
♪ Backs on my knees ♪
♪ Can a silly trap door ♪
♪ Laser currency be? ♪
♪ He say can a silly trap door ♪
- Hey, what the hell are we sayin', man?
- I got no idea man.
I'm just hungry and talking about
the galaxy and trains.
I think they're buyin' it, though.
(audience applauding)
- One at a time.
I put men like you behind bars everyday.
One at a time.
♪ Like a toad, you may take my years ♪
♪ But cannot lock my soul away ♪
♪ Oh the years I had to - ♪
♪ I've chased you through these ♪
♪ years ♪
♪ So long ago, ♪
♪ it all began ♪
♪ Now your journey's ♪
♪ at an end ♪
♪ In the shadows are my shame ♪
♪ You will pay for what you've done ♪
♪ But was I ever ♪
♪ made? ♪
♪ Will be your only friend ♪
♪ Do I let this fight end now ♪
♪ Do not interrupt me ♪
♪ Just to end this life of pain ♪
♪ Let me finish what I need to say ♪
♪ Will you be welcome now ♪
♪ Fine, I'll let you finish first ♪
♪ Don't let my journey be in vein ♪
♪ Don't let me get in your way ♪
♪ I only stole a loaf of bread ♪
♪ I am finished now ♪
♪ All I needed to survive ♪
♪ Okay, now it's my turn ♪
♪ If I end up in your cell ♪
♪ Can we have some give and take? ♪
♪ I would and am still alive ♪
♪ Let me get in a word at least ♪
♪ Do I tell him that I love him? ♪
♪ Do I tell him of his child? ♪
♪ Now where did this bitch come from? ♪
♪ I have no idea ♪
♪ One at a time ♪
♪ Will he ever know ♪
♪ his daughter? ♪
♪ Lady seriously, ♪
♪ please head home ♪
♪ Will he recognize ♪
♪ her eyes? ♪
♪ It's (indistinct) ♪
♪ So talk to him ♪
♪ Did you say my daughter? ♪
♪ Yours and mine ♪
♪ One at a time ♪
♪ It's all a free ♪
♪ Now this is just a joke ♪
♪ May our parents hear our voices ♪
♪ May we capture should be fine ♪
♪ One at a time ♪
♪ Taking what we can ♪
♪ 'Cause things are getting worse ♪
♪ From every pocket and purse ♪
♪ One at a time ♪
♪ What men have done ♪
♪ You destroyed the man ♪
♪ She will be for ♪
♪ Glory, glory, glory ♪
♪ Glory shall be mine ♪
♪ We will die ♪
♪ I will die ♪
♪ Years, they pass ♪
♪ Can we speak? ♪
♪ One at a time ♪
♪ Here we go again ♪
♪ Why are we all facing the same way? ♪
- In this city on fire?
What's with all the smoke?
Oh, now we're all ears.
Great.
(boots plodding)
(upbeat techno music)
♪ Well tonight we gonna party ♪
♪ 'Till the party don't stop ♪
♪ And the party don't stop ♪
♪ Because it keeps on going ♪
♪ Nonstop, gonna party all night ♪
♪ Gonna keep this party going ♪
♪ 'Cause the party won't stop ♪
♪ It's been two straight days ♪
♪ And the party's still goin' ♪
♪ Two, three, four,
five, six, seven days ♪
♪ 'Till it's Friday again ♪
♪ And the party keeps going ♪
♪ Party all night ♪
♪ 'Cause it's that all night party ♪
♪ Friday night ♪
♪ 9 PM ♪
♪ Hop in the car ♪
♪ Call my friends ♪
♪ Drinks in the back ♪
♪ Girls up front ♪
♪ Going to a party ♪
♪ Sent them texts ♪
♪ Cell phone rings ♪
♪ iPad, Facebook ♪
♪ Party time ♪
♪ Skintight jeans ♪
♪ Friday nights ♪
♪ Dance, dance, dance ♪
♪ 'Cause tonight we goin' on ♪
♪ And we ain't comin' back ♪
♪ 'Cause the party won't stop ♪
♪ It will go all night ♪
♪ Friday night ♪
♪ Every night the party's going down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down, down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down ♪
♪ New York City, L.A., Chicago ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego ♪
♪ Phoenix, Austin, Fort Worth, ♪
♪ Boston, Memphis, Denver ♪
♪ Portland, Vegas ♪
♪ Tucson, Fresno, Akron ♪
♪ Tampa, Pittsburgh, Newark ♪
♪ Plano, Lincoln, Lubbock ♪
♪ Durham, Salem, Dayton ♪
♪ Cities, cities, cities ♪
♪ Cities ♪
♪ 'Cause tonight ♪
♪ We going out and we ain't coming back ♪
♪ 'Cause the party won't stop ♪
♪ and we'll go all night ♪
♪ Friday night, every night ♪
♪ the party's going down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down, down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down ♪
♪ New York city, L.A., Chicago ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego ♪
♪ Phoenix, Austin, Fort Worth ♪
♪ Boston, Memphis, Denver, ♪
♪ Portland, Vegas ♪
♪ Tucson, Fresno, Akron ♪
♪ Tampa, Pittsburgh, Newark ♪
♪ Plano, Lincoln, Lubbock ♪
♪ Durham, Salem, Dayton ♪
♪ Cities, cities, cities, cities ♪
♪ Cities ♪
♪ Yeah we're gonna keep it going ♪
♪ To the break of break of dawn ♪
♪ Then we'll just keep
partying all day long ♪
♪ Hot girls, music, dancing ♪
♪ And bikinis and head phones ♪
♪ Party, party, party, party ♪
(gun firing)
♪ So tonight we gonna party ♪
♪ 'Till the party don't stop ♪
- What you think it is?
- Hey, what's up y'all?
(group greeting him)
- Hey, what y'all guys playin'?
- Oh nothin', just a little DVD, right?
- What DVD?
- It came for you in the mail.
It says to my fresh dope son from MC mom.
- I can't wait to see it.
- No, no, wait, wait.
(group chastising)
- If there's one thing
- Guys, guys!
- we're gonna do today,
we are playing that DVD.
Come on.
- Come on, man.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yes.
- Oh God.
(R&B music)
- Please, man.
- Did you produce this track?
No, no.
- Hold it, hold it.
Nope, nope.
♪ Yo ♪
- Okay, we got on the mom jeans.
- Look at the sweater.
♪ I'm the M to the C ♪
♪ To the MOM ♪
♪ And when it comes to mom rappers ♪
♪ I'm the biggity best of them ♪
- Is she rappin'?
♪ Sending out this rhyme ♪
♪ To my homie number one ♪
♪ His name's Carl Stewart ♪
♪ But to me he's just son ♪
♪ Word up ♪
- God.
- Okay,
she got that runnin' man down.
- Can we please turn this off?
- Your mom said turn it up.
- Turn up.
♪ You left some stuff behind ♪
♪ That I can send you if ya need ♪
♪ Like your best friend bear ♪
♪ And your magazines ♪
♪ Going through all this stuff ♪
♪ But it looks pretty risky ♪
♪ You use so much lotion ♪
♪ But your socks sure are crispy. ♪
- Oh.
- Mom,
come on, Mom!
- Okay.
♪ I've been cleaning with the broom ♪
♪ And the vacuum and found ♪
♪ Victoria's Secret is
she's hiding in your room ♪
♪ Every nook and cranny ♪
♪ There are wads of tissue ♪
♪ I can't even open this swimsuit issue. ♪
- Man, what is wrong with you bruh?
- I spilled a soda on that magazine.
- Right.
♪ I'm getting your sheets
so nice and clean ♪
♪ Like when you wet your
bed 'till you were 16 ♪
- Why?
- Okay.
♪ I overreacted ♪
♪ Sorry I spanked you ♪
♪ Look another crispy sock ♪
♪ No thank you ♪
- Oh!
- Why?
- She sniffed -
- That is wrong.
- How many crispy socks
she gonna find, dog?
♪ Crispy socks here ♪
♪ Crispy socks there ♪
♪ Crispy socks with some mystery hair ♪
- We're gotta turn it off right now.
Come on you guys, come on.
- We started it, we gonna finish it.
♪ Oh ah the beat changed up ♪
♪ I got the kitchen ♪
♪ And the basement and the living room ♪
♪ And since your dad met that bitch ♪
♪ I've got his office too ♪
♪ Got my juices goin' ♪
♪ My rhymes flowin' ♪
♪ My breath blowin' ♪
♪ Showin' no signs of slowin' ♪
♪ I can fill my skills growin' ♪
♪ Took a little practice ♪
♪ To practice these lyrical gymnastics ♪
♪ But now the fact is queen bee I'ma be ♪
♪ Throwin' out your (beeping) mattress ♪
♪ Hell yeah ♪
♪ Baddest bitch in the biz ♪
♪ Takin' the show on the road ♪
♪ You can clean up your own jizz, (beep) ♪
♪ Peace ♪
(explosion sounding)
(group cheering)
- Yo MC Mom put the
pussy on the chain wax.
- Spare some change?
- Sorry man, I ain't got nothing.
- All right.
(sirens sounding)
- Hold it right there.
Let's see some ID.
- I wasn't even doing anything, man.
- Are you talking back to me?
- No, I was just walking man.
- Look, there is no reason
for you to get upset, sir.
- I'm not, I'm not.
- All right that's it.
Put your hands on your head.
- Put my hands up?
- Put your hands on your head, yes.
You had your chance.
- Listen man, can I just ask you,
politely, what it is that I did?
- You think I was born yesterday?
- Come on, man, I was -
- Get in the car.
Duck your head.
- All right, officer.
I'll take it from here.
- Well hi Wally.
Good to see you.
He's all yours.
- All right.
- Y'all have a good night.
- Thanks man, but where we goin'?
- I'm glad you asked.
(door opening)
Follow me.
- Through there?
(magical chiming)
Whoa, look at this place.
Where are we?
- Just be patient and I'll show you.
- What? Your suit changed.
♪ Follow me to a place I know ♪
♪ Where there ain't no pain ♪
♪ Ain't no sorrow ♪
♪ It's a place to be ♪
♪ If your skin is brown ♪
♪ I'm talkin' bout ♪
♪ Negrotown ♪
- Negrotown, what like Atlanta?
- Almost.
Now be quiet while I sing.
♪ In Negrotown you can walk the street ♪
♪ Without getting stopped ♪
♪ Harassed or beat ♪
♪ And there's always a cab ♪
♪ When you need to around ♪
(horn honking)
- And they always stop
♪ In Negrotown ♪
- I think I get it now.
It's like a utopia for black people.
- Yeah, but seriously, shut the (beep) up.
♪ Won't get followed ♪
♪ When you try to shop ♪
♪ You can wear your hoodie ♪
♪ And not get shot ♪
♪ No white folks to cross
the street in fear ♪
♪ No trigger happy cops ♪
♪ Or scared cashiers ♪
♪ That loan application
can't get turned down ♪
♪ You're always approved in Negrotown ♪
- This is amazing.
- I know, right?
♪ We are going down to Negrotown ♪
♪ Where the strong black
man are raining down ♪
♪ There's light skin ♪
♪ Dark skin and every shade ♪
♪ And there's no white bitches ♪
♪ To take them away ♪
- This sounds too good to be true.
- It does, doesn't it?
But can I (beeping) finish the song?
I mean, can a (beep) finish?
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
♪ In Negrotown you live long and well ♪
♪ There's no disease, no sickle cell ♪
♪ No stupid ass white
folks touching your hair ♪
♪ Or stealing your culture
claiming it's theirs ♪
♪ Hanging out in a group ♪
♪ Doesn't make you a gang ♪
♪ Every word that you say ♪
♪ Ain't considered slang ♪
♪ No one tryin' to get in ♪
♪ On the latest trend ♪
♪ By making you their token black friend ♪
♪ A place where harmony is found ♪
♪ It's a mother (beeping)
black playground ♪
♪ Talkin' 'bout Negrotown! ♪
♪ Talkin' 'bout Negro ♪
♪ Negro Negro Negro ♪
♪ Talking 'bout Negrotown! ♪
(music fades)
(theme music)